If you've been forced
into a high school death game
and all of your classmates
are dying in savage ways.
What do you do?
There's no one to help you,
and you must follow
every command of the king,
no matter how brutal they get,
the death game doesn't end
until there's only one of you left alive.
I'm going to break down the mistakes made.
What you should do and how to beat
the death game in Kings game.
This classroom is going
to turn into a bloodbath.
Nobu here is a normal high school student.
He's relaxing with his friends and doing
everything a normal teenager would do, but
they don't realize their lives are about
to turn into a bloody battle royale.
A classroom full of teenagers
is sent a creepy message.
They've all been entered
into the Kings game.
The rules are every student
must participate.
You have 24 hours to carry out
the orders of the king,
and quitting is not an option.
Before they know it,
the king has already sent his first order.
This blond guy here
must touch this quiet girl's chest.
He tries to grab her
to complete the order.
But before he can finish,
he stopped by her friends.
They think they're doing the right thing,
but they've just made the biggest mistake
of their lives that night.
Our protagonist, Nobu, is sleeping
peacefully before he wakes up
to a follow up text from the king.
The text orders a nerdy student
and a girl who already has
a boyfriend to hook up,
thinking nothing of these weird attacks.
He goes back to his beauty
sleep the next day.
His teacher reveals that the blond guy
and the quiet's girl
he was ordered to
touch have died due to unknown causes.
They really should have obeyed the order.
OK, this is terrifying.
I'm only a high school student
and two of my classmates have just
been killed by some crazy murderer.
This is serious business, and there's no
doubt it's about to get much more twisted.
If I'm Nobu, I'd be really pissed
to myself right now.
I decided to get some more beauty sleep
because apparently
I needed to be beautiful.
But I'm only a teenager.
There's not much
I can do without adult supervision.
I would at least tell my teacher
that I received a text
from the so-called king late last night
telling others about the game
was not against the rules we received.
And with this information,
we could forward it to the authorities
with more time capabilities
and access to technology than me.
A regular Japanese junior high school
usually has around 30 kids
per class in a grade, knowing
that the king is targeting a single class.
And since the rules state,
it's only the members of that class
that have to participate in the game.
I would test out here if switching a class
would count as quitting the game.
To accomplish this,
I would convince
one of the TRAUMATIZE students
who was a friend of those recently
murdered kids, to ask the principal
to let them switch to another class
for the rest of the year.
It might not work, but
using them as a guinea pig keeps us safe.
And if they remain alive after that,
I would congratulate them for being
a great test subject and tailgates
right behind them out of this game.
I'll tell the principal that
the two who died were my best friends,
and I want to switch classes
because I'm also so traumatized.
I'm sure those two what in mind
they're already dead anyway, knowing that
these texts were sent out by an unknown
number also gives us a good lead.
I would trying to find their location
through a bit of computer wizardry.
You can find someone's location
through their number
by using a process
known as cell triangulation.
I know that's a big word.
So follow along, people.
This technology figures out
the general location of the user
by analyzing a triangle
formed by three cell towers
that interacted with that phone.
Ideally, the police will do this for us.
But if we can't get their help, tracking
this phone signal is the best chance
we have right now in figuring out
who the king is terrified by the game.
The nerdy student
and the girl with the boyfriend
who were ordered to hook up earlier
obey the king's order.
They do the deed and remain alive.
But sadly, for the nerdy student,
this girl's boyfriend is out for revenge.
The next day, the boyfriend starts
beating on the nerdy student, and that's
when the worst possible thing happens.
The next student picks up by
the king is the boyfriend himself.
He's allowed to announce
an order of his choice
to any one student in front of the class,
not realizing what he's doing.
The boyfriend half jokingly have an anger,
orders the nerdy student to die.
Phone started ringing
and the next text is sent to the class.
We find out from the king
that the nerdy kid will die at midnight.
Nobody here takes the nerdy kid
to band practice in order to keep him
safe, where no one can harm him
until the clock hits midnight.
The boys have a sick night full of music,
and when 12am comes, he's still alive.
The boys have a celebration
and relax, thinking.
Then they finally be in the game.
The nerdy kid goes to get some drinks
and suddenly Nobu
gets a text, which says
Obedience confirmed.
He runs to the back room
to find a disgusting scene.
The Kings game has savagely murdered
another innocent teenager.
All right. That was really stupid.
These two guys shouldn't
have led their guards down.
Just because the clock hit midnight
does not mean our friend is safe,
especially considering that
he exited the room at 12:00 or 1:00 a.m.
We already know that some crazy shit
is going on with this Kings game
, so we shouldn't take any chances.
What I would do is stay with my friend
for at least a few hours
now just to save his life,
but to figure out what I can learn
from his death from the text.
We know exactly when he's going to die,
but we don't know how he's going to die.
This was a perfect opportunity to
figure out how these deaths are happening.
And Nobu here completely blew it
with our current knowledge,
since we don't know anything for certain.
One assumption we can make here is that
our friend was somehow brainwashed.
The text could be causing
some sort of mind control,
which is forcing
the students to be killed in various ways.
Mobile phones are banned in airplanes
and hospitals for a reason.
Phones send out electromagnetic signals
which are proven to interfere
with electrical devices.
Our brain has similar characteristics
to an electrical device, which means
it might be affected in the same way.
Right now, technology
like that doesn't exist yet.
But after something like
this is happening under our noses,
we should always consider first
that we're dealing
with an unknown technology
before jumping to the conclusion
that it's magic.
It's possible someone tampered with
our phones to give them this capability.
And it would explain why this whole game
is run through our phones.
The king might be
some sort of crazy scientist,
and there could be a chance of him
remotely controlling our friend's brain.
This means we need to keep
a strong eye on him,
maybe even going as far as tying him up
so he can't run anywhere.
And if that doesn't work, at least
we'll get to see firsthand how it happens.
I'm sure he will understand.
It'll make for a great show.
Bring the popcorn.
The next day, the class receives
another text saying
that a popularity contest will be held.
The two contestants are this guy
who is Nobu, his best friend,
and this brown haired girl.
The contest is neck and neck with the
brown haired girl taking the final vote.
This means the best friend here
is about to be punished.
Suddenly they realized
another piece of paper remains.
And it's a note from one of the students
switching their vote
from the brown haired
girl to the best friend.
She is so distressed to hear this,
she decides to take matters
into her own hands and quits the game
before the Kings game does it for her.
But then in a moment of irony,
they receive a text from the king,
and it turns out her punishment
for losing the vote
wasn't going to be death at all.
Her punishment was simply to confess
her feelings to a person that she likes.
Guess you can say that
she jumped to the wrong conclusion.
It turns out somehow she survives
the fall, but is now in critical
condition. Nobu Shiomi
and the best friend away to the hospital.
But it's all for nothing.
The brown haired girl flatlines and
becomes the next victim of the Kings game.
Now that she's gone,
the Kings game sends its next order.
The best friend is now
ordered to have sex by midnight,
or else he'll be burnt alive.
But there's a catch.
The time right now is 11, 50 p.m.
with only 10 minutes left,
Nobu here is forced to ask his girlfriend
to carry out the order, not wanting
to have sex with his girlfriend.
The best friend refuses.
So Nobu knocked him out
and she does the deed.
Obedience confirmed
the best friend has completed his order.
NAMI here is the next to be picked.
Her order is as follows.
She's allowed to create any order of her
liking because of this.
She has what she thinks is a smart idea.
She sends out in order to herself
that says she must touch the king
before the clock hits midnight,
gathering the class together.
She lines everyone up
and touches them one by one.
It seems like a genius tactic
in order to expose who the king really is.
But by the time the last person
is touched, a moment of silence follows.
And that's when things
start to go very wrong.
NAMI runs away in shock,
knowing that since she hasn't completed
the order, she's going to die.
Nobu chases after her and finds her
sitting by the river as midnight hits.
She's punished, but her punishment
is not death. Instead,
her vision is taken away from her,
and she is now permanently blind.
I guess you can say
she didn't see that coming right after.
Nobody here has sent a text
saying he will lose something important,
but he doesn't know what.
The next day, Nobu smashes
all of his personal belongings
and tries to break over Chemi
because he thinks that
it might prevent the game from taking away
something even more important.
But that's when he realizes there's
nothing he can do.
NAMI calls him up to say
her final goodbyes.
She has just become another victim
of the Kings game, obedience confirmed.
I guess it's obvious to state
that Naomi's idea to order herself
wasn't that smart and a king's game
if you involve yourself in an order.
All it takes is for one thing to go wrong
and you're dead.
There are so many possibilities
she could have taken
with her unique order.
We still don't know who are what
the king is, but we do know it's capable
of some near supernatural stuff.
And we definitely haven't
received a strong enough indication
that the king is one of our classmates.
She took way too big of a risk.
Like I said before, tracking down
a number is pretty easy these days,
and it would have been even easier
if the killer was in the same school.
But this is getting really scary.
Nobu had the right idea
by staying next to NAMI.
But despite all his efforts,
it looks like the king has won again
and by making her go blind.
The king seems way too powerful,
but I don't think all hope is lost.
The first thing I would at least try to do
is take Nomy to the hospital.
While there have never been cases
of blindness from a death game,
there have been scientifically proven
causes of blindness due to stress
when a person is severely stressed.
A spike in adrenaline
can cause pressure to build up on our eyes
and blur our vision.
Over time, the heightened cortisol levels
caused by stress
can result in damaged nerves.
And fluid buildup in the eye
leading to loss of vision.
That's great, taking her to the hospital
gives us another opportunity
to analyze the situation
and find out more about the king.
If we can figure out how the blindness was
caused, it might give us information
that can save our own butts later.
There are many different ways
of going blind, which might be due
to injury, disease or infection.
Maybe if we find out how the blindness was
cost, we could get a lead on the king
and figure out how he's
causing these supernatural deaths.
But Nahmias fate was just the beginning.
Savage deaths have been happening
all over the class.
One of the classmates
died of natural causes.
Another fell down the stairs
and one suffered a fatal seizure.
The next text from the king
is sent to the class, stating
that no one is allowed to do anything
deemed forbidden.
Fasten your seatbelts.
There's about to be a whole boatload
of gruesome deaths.
Student number 30 explodes
into a million pieces.
Student number 25
and 28 are killed by suffocation.
Student number 20
and 16 are punished by decapitation.
Student number five is set on fire
and burnt alive.
Student number 29
is punished by dismemberment.
Student number 11 suffers a heart attack.
That wasn't the worst one.
This is an absolute bloodbath.
The boyfriend from before
calls Nobu revealing that he tried to
block the number and is now about to die.
They also find out another girl
died due to canceling her SIM card.
These two forgot one of the rules
from the start of the game.
Quitting is not an option. Before
even a minute passes.
Student number 13 calls
before imploding into a bloody mess,
figuring out by quitting or blocking
the game will end in death.
He contacts one of the survivors
and tells her this newfound information
and that they shouldn't
disconnect their phones.
But after he hangs up, a message is sent.
Student number 31 is to be punished
by heart attack.
And another one stating student number
four is to be burnt alive.
Nobu here failed to inform them in time
after thinking about it for a little bit.
Nobody here realizes that
everyone who died had been crying
when they received their punishment.
This means that crying is the forbidden
rule that everyone's been breaking.
Being the nice guy that he is,
he calls the rest of the class and informs
them of what he's just learned.
This blue haired guy here
calls the main character
and reveals that he's done some research
and figured out that the Kings game
started in a place called Yanakie Village.
The history of the village was hidden
after every single villager mysteriously
died and the killer was unable to be found
while talking to Nobu .
He accidentally cries,
but manages to send off his research
to him before his arms and legs
explode off of his body.
Straight after this.
Nobu tries to go to Yanakie Village,
but is knocked out by a mysterious figure.
When he wakes up, he figures out that it's
the blue haired guy's girlfriend,
thinking that Nobu is the king.
She attacks the main character
before coming to her senses.
He explains what happened to the boyfriend
and convinces her to untie him
saddened by the news.
She cries and lets the main character
go before dying of a heart attack.
OK, so the origin of the Kings
game started from
an old abandoned village
where everyone mysteriously died.
How is it taken us this long
to find out why the way
we need to tell this to our classmates?
There's no way I can tackle this alone.
The Internet will be one of
our biggest weapons in beating this game.
Yanagi Village is something that should be
a piece of Internet folklore.
All it takes is for a simple post
on social media websites
to spread the word about this
hidden village in Japan
where everyone died
by some invisible entity.
There's no doubt in my mind
that people would dedicate time and effort
to researching what happened
in this mystical village.
If our blue haired friend
can find out what he has by himself,
imagine what the Internet could do
and what I could do.
But the problem with this strategy is
it will take time.
Every order must be obeyed
within 24 hours.
And by the time the Internet figures it
out, it might be too late for us.
Which is why I would only use this
as a distraction tactic.
And in the meantime, use
the new information we just learned
in order to win the game
by doing one simple thing.
I would assemble
all the members of my class together
and tell them what happened.
I would show them the email
my blue haired friend sacrificed his life
for and try my best
to convince them to tag along.
If we all go as a group,
we might have a chance
of finding some clues in the village
that would help us with beating the king.
Maybe some previous players
of the game left some notes
in their houses before dying.
Utilizing the group to help search
for more clues will ensure we get this
show on the road and get to the bottom
of this as every minute counts.
And while the group is busy searching,
I would sneakily put on some goggles
and make my way to the kitchen
to chop onions. Why?
Well, the chemical released from chopped
onions is called Antheil s oxide,
and it is a latra meter which stimulates
the tear glands and makes you cry.
This means we can easily
prepare unnatural tear gas,
and when I invite
to the other students to dinner,
they'll have a nasty surprise
waiting for them.
We can even bring with us some pepper
spray in case there are some stragglers
who succeed in holding their tears
in and ensure our victory.
But personally, I think
the onions are more fun.
It might sound cold blooded,
and that's because it is.
But this is life and death.
And now that we know, crying forces
you to. Lose the game.
It's a golden opportunity that we can't
afford to waste, the next order is sent.
One of the members of the class
will volunteer to roll the dice.
Whatever number is
given will be the amount of people
who will die along with the roller.
The roller is to voice out
the names of those he or she wants dead.
The group gathers at a park by the dam
and know who's best friend.
Here is the one who takes the bullet.
He rolls the dice and is unlucky enough
to get a six to ensure his safety.
This ugly guy here snatches chisme,
stabbing her in the leg.
The group starts arguing and chaos ensues.
The best friend accidentally says
the name of the short kid here
who is the first to go.
His neck spins around his head
like a steering wheel until it falls off.
And, well, pop goes
the weasel. Sucks to be him.
The best friend picks a sick girl who's
stuck in the hospital as the next to die.
This brown haired girl
and the angry looking one.
Here are the next to meet their demise.
With the situation at hand,
there aren't many options left.
This ugly guy here
is about to force the best friend
to pick Nobu as the next to die.
But in the nick of time, the frazzled guy
punches him square in the face, freeing
chemi freckles, then volunteers for him
and the ugly guy to become
the next victims, bleeding to death
on the spot with six people dead .
There's only one more left,
and the victims has already been decided.
The best friend gives Nobu
and Simmy words of support
before being torn limb from limb.
Now there are only three remaining.
This white haired
girl hair whips out a laptop and reveals
that she's been researching
and found out even more information
about the origins of the game.
The first Kings game happened
over 30 years ago,
where the orders were delivered on paper
instead of text.
Eventually, all the
villagers started dying
and the police couldn't
do anything to help.
Scientists began to research and found
that the king is not actually a person
at all, but a form of computer virus
that's linked with the game .
Apparently, these
orders are a form of infectious disease
that can cause hypnosis strong enough
to cause all of the crazy deaths
since the game never ended in the village.
The virus evolved to spread
from biological to technological means.
This is why now has the ability to infect
people through electronic devices.
She notices one more thing.
Everyone who was killed in the game
receives a one syllable text message
from the king before they get punished.
But she doesn't know what it means yet.
She tries using an antivirus program
to exploit a bug that she found
within the game's programing.
But the king is full of surprises.
She's punished for breaking
one of the rules set from the very start.
No quitting allowed.
She instantly catches on fire and
is burnt alive for trying to end the game.
It turns out the bug was a trap set
by the king who expected someone
to try and to exploit it.
OK, if this girl acted fast,
she might have been able
to prevent her own death.
She's been told that she's going to burst
into flames and were right next to a dam.
She looks to be wearing
a pretty flammable sweater.
So she's made the right choice
by taking it off,
even though it's embarrassing.
If I was her, I would not be taking
my time and immediately
jump into the water.
A human caught on fire
will pass out in a matter of seconds
as the brain slowly shuts off,
leading to a painful death.
Also, it looks like a pretty big drop
to maximize her chances of survival.
She'll need to cross her legs
and hit the water feet first.
She might break her legs,
but at least she'll survive.
Maybe diving headfirst
into a drop like that
will result in a ninety nine point
nine percent chance of death jumping feet.
First is typically how the military
is trained to jump into water
off of high platforms,
such as off of an aircraft carrier.
When it's time to abandon ship.
Now, as far as we know, spontaneous
human combustion is a concept
that has arguably zero
recorded cases in human history.
So unfortunately for us,
it seems like the king might be able
to defy the laws of chemistry and reality.
Either way, we have to try what we can.
If we make it into the water,
we'll have a good chance of surviving.
Unless it's Greek fire, then we're doomed.
It didn't work out for me
last night. I tried.
There have never been cases of people
surviving large wildfires
by hiding out in their backyard pool.
The only way to beat this punishment
would be to stay submerged in the water
for as long as possible
while taking small breaks for air.
The king may decide
to let up after a while.
Nobu and Shimmy are now the final
two players of the Kings game.
The last order is simple and a most cruel
kill the person you love most.
In the end, Chemi chooses
to sacrifice herself in order
to save the main character's life.
Even though Jianmei might not have been
the person he loves most, he's
now the last man standing.
Suddenly, he receives his final message
Continue the Kings game
or choose to be punished.
Some time later,
we see Naboo moving to a new school.
His first day of school is like any other.
But after all that he's
seen in the king's game,
it makes it kind of hard for him
to make any friends
with the school sports festival providing
lots of excitement and joy.
He starts to forget about the horrible
things he's experienced and finally starts
to line up just before
he's about to hit the hay.
The clock hits midnight.
A text is sent to the class stating
This is the king's game.
The king's orders are absolute.
You have 24 hours
and quitting is not an option.
Looks like he chose
the first option to continue.
It's time for the next game,
and by the end of it,
they'll finally find out the crucial
meaning behind the king's one
syllable messages
that were sent to every dead student.
And the next game in question
will involve smashing the leg bone,
subscribing to our channel.
And please leave a comment down below,
letting us know what you like,
what you didn't like.
But do it quickly
before the Kings game gets you.